Speaker 1: . You know, a lot has been made
of how the Bush family, they're more serious
Republicans.
You know, they don't support Trump, George
W. Bush, not a big Trump guy.
Jeb Bush, seemingly not a big Trump guy.
But in comes George P. Bush, and he's just
on his knees, seemingly praying at the altar
of Trump.
And I think I know what it is that's going
on here.
He sounds almost like Kuhnen in this interview.
Check this out where he says, no, no, no,
I'm my own man and Trump is great.
This this Bush loves Trump.
Take a look.
Speaker 4: And so when I talk about my record,
whether it says land commissioner or my support
of Trump, you know, I just stick to the facts.
The fact is that in 2016, I was one of the
first statewide elected officials to come
out and support him.
I raise a million and a half in support of
Republican candidates with him at the top
of the ticket and as a high watermark for
Republican Party politics in the state of
Texas.
And then twenty twenty, I boldly declared
that Trump was the only thing standing between
our country, the American people and socialism.
And lo and behold, I've turned out to be correct
with over 30 trillion in total spending, six
trillion and just next year's annual budget.
So, yeah, when you look at my policies, I'm
all about America first.
Trump is the center of the Republican Party.
I'm my own man.
I support him and we need to carry on.
That legacy captured the lightning that he
brought to the Republican Party so that we
can help all of our fellow Republicans down
ballot.
Speaker 3: So through the holiday season this
year, you're the son of Jeb Bush.
The conversations must be fascinating, are
very strong, very distinct in your support
for the president.
We know that many members of your family do
not like him.
Is there been any pressure on you?
What is the do you not have those conversations?
How how do you handle that?
Speaker 4: Well, I think we're just like any
American family and that we have our differences
of opinion, whether it's with respect to President
Trump, whether it's respect to hot button
issues,
Speaker 1: I mean, again, it's very similar
to the type of stuff you hear at a Trump rally,
right.
Trump stopped socialism in its tracks and
now Biden is proof of how important that was
come out of this world sort of stuff.
And what I would love to see asked is a question
here is, OK, George P. Bush, that's interesting.
Do since you support Trump and you think Trump's
great, was Trump right when Trump said that
your uncle George W. Bush, lied us into a
pointless war with Iraq, would George P. Bush
agree with that?
Is Trump the Lord and Savior on that particular
question?
I think this is nothing other than obvious
brazened brownnosing for future help from
Donald Trump, if indeed Donald Trump is still
in a position of power.
And what I mean by that is George P. Bush
is running for Texas attorney general.
Texas is almost certainly going to play a
major role in the future of American politics.
Maybe even in twenty twenty four, Trump might
be back in.
Trump might be the Republican nominee in twenty
twenty four.
Trump, being president or not, could depend
on Texas.
And Trump would absolutely crush this guy
if he doesn't get in line.
That's fundamentally what's going on here.
I don't even know if George P. Bush really
believes this stuff like some part of me is
OK.
George P. Bush is so wacky that he thinks
Trump is great.
That's terrible.
It's a huge indictment of George P. Bush.
The other side is he's just a liar and he's
of the George W. Bush, Jeb Bush, George H.W.
Bush mindset about Trump.
But he's saying this stuff because he thinks
it will benefit him in the future because
he might need need Trump's help, or at least
he wants to avoid Trump's disdain.
Either way, it's vile.
Either the guy is an idiot or he's a complete
and total liar.
And I don't know which is worse, but it's
it's not good.
Not good is the way I would describe it.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter.
Let me know what you think about George P.
Bush.
Does he believe this stuff about Trump or
is he simply trying to play towards Trump's
support at some point in the future when he
needs it?
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
Let me know what a great program we have for
you today.
We'll take some of your calls next.
We've had two weeks in a row of beautiful
calls.
I'm feeling pretty good about a third week
and then much more coming up.
Stay with us.
Remember that The David Pakman Show is mostly
funded by members, it is the much maligned
but never equaled world famous and award winning
bonus show.
Yeah, I know that the rewards we give out,
but who cares?
Join at join Pakman dot com.
Very easy.
We do an extra show every day for our members
and it's just a good time.
It's just a good time